what i recommend to everybody right now  is make a list of your top three  architectural firms that you want to  work for and not just firms that you  want to apply to after you've narrowed  down your top three firms make sure you  email and call every single one of them  and if you can also try to arrange an  in-person meeting ask for just three  minutes of their time don't ask for 5 10  15 ask for three you want to ask for an  extremely short period of time that most  logical people cannot say no to you want  to make sure you come into it very  quickly with rapid fire questions to get  in and out of three minutes so that you  respect their time and they respect you  but in the same time you want to develop  these relationships  so by simply forming connections with  architectural firms you want to work for  you not only figure out what  architectural software they use how they  render how they present and how you can  master those exact softwares you also  build relationship